we just heard is your dad going back to
SNL that is gonna be so much fun like do
you like watching him do you ever go and
watch it live yeah I have no idea it is
actually people ask me so many questions
about like have asked me so many
questions tonight about that I'm like he
you know American needed that and we all
needed that I feel like and I know a lot
of people would disagree but I really
think you know he did a tremendous job
and just kind of letting us all have a
bit of a laugh and all of the horrible
horrible news of it all really I don't
even know what words to put together for
that but you don't I mean you just he
really helped us I feel like helped us
all get through it and it was so amazing
seeing it life and watching him in the
process and watching him to come trauma
you know you're looking amazing in blue
so I have to ask could you rock blue as
a bridesmaid in an upcoming Haley Justin
wedding have you been asked for that yet
no I have not I have no idea what their
situation is what's going on
you know I think that they're just
taking things slow and
so many reports out there every minute
it's like they got their marriage
license now they're getting a prenup
what's actually happening they're just
kissing all over the world they're just
kissing and loving and having fun and I
think people take little details and get
too caught up in them and they're
looking too hard into it then just let
them kiss in Big Bend Eiffel Tower you
textin are like girl where else can you
kiss I should I should actually make a
collage and send it to her and see if
she wants it can you put this to rest
will they do like I could see them doing
such an amazing big wedding but they've
been saying small I think what are they
gonna do
knowing Haley it'll be small she's very
she loves a little intimate you know I
sound like a wedding planner right now
she loves and intimate gathering on the
I sound like um like the fabulous life
of you know those shows remember you
could do that you know what you used to
put like they don't know the person at
all but they're like she loves and
Jennifer Aniston loves a bottle of no
it's like how did you know I don't know
but I think she'd love just family being
close and his family and that's why does
it feel right for you guys like how
happy are they and how do you like
seeing them together it was meant to be
a long time ago it was just a long time
coming and we're all like alright thank
God well here forward now woo yeah
totally they're so in love and they
really do a lot of good for each other
and that's the most important thing for
that he makes her so happy and so
connected and how could you tell they
were meant to be a long time ago that's
like crazy and amazing
I just think they've gone through a lot
of trial and error as individuals and
together and I think that you know
that's really what withstands and what
holds a relationship and really proves
it's worth and that it's meant to be you
know and they've proved it I think and I
love you and you say they make each
other better how do they do that
you know they just bring out the good in
each other they really do and I think
they do a really good job of checking
each other when one desperately needs to
be checked and told you know you're out
of line I think that they really really
do care about each other so much and
care about what others and what their
families think of them and ever they're
just very they're very respectable
couple so you haven't asked to advise me
but will you be involved in this wedding
like or is it gonna be that small I have
no idea I really have no idea I don't
even know when it's gonna be as they're
gonna save the date no we can't wait to
see it I also want to ask you about just
I don't even open up about some issues
of your own lately which I just love
seeing as a woman and what was that like
for you and why was it important for you
to do that it's really hard actually you
know in modeling I think it's definitely
hard finding your place and finding what
your brand is because I feel like
everyone is a model now and everyone is
an actor and everyone is a internet
personality and everyone it's just so
boring and I'm like alright if I'm gonna
be in this business and I'm
what I'm doing I want to have a voice
for good and I want to do something I
want to stand for something and help
people and you know people aren't gonna
like me and that's fine and I understand
that and I wouldn't honestly I would get
I wouldn't like me there if I was the
daughter of somebody that's just
modeling and doing it I wanted I want to
do something that people what can relate
to and be proud of and really think you
know oh wow like she you know she has a
brain so you know it's something that
I've you know helped many girls and I've
had so many people help me through that
time in my life and I think it's really
important to share what I've learned you
know how are you feeling now and what's
next for you work wise as we navigate
this crazy modeling world a lot of
really great things modeling we're wise
on the horizon I can't talk as I just
flew back from Milan yesterday so I'm
like not alive but yeah I mean modeling
has been amazing my agents are amazing
and they work their asses off for me and
you know also acting wise I'm really
starting to discover what it is I want
to do and who I am and kind of where I
belong in that world so you know it's
just all a process it takes time and we
got a lot of acting blend the family
what advice do the family members give
you on all of it they say you know just
go for it honestly like I'm such a fear
like even tonight presenting I'm the
worst public speaker I'm gonna something
up probably sorry I don't know how to
say that but I am and you know I go into
an audition it's shaking and like a near
panic attack and they really taught me
how to just like calm down and let go
and breathe and be like you know what if
you don't get it you don't get it but
you're gonna get the right thing if you
work hard enough I think your dad's like
a fierce papa does he ever come at you
for any the modelling you've done like
hey I don't know if I liked that
pictures oh my god
yeah Hilson he makes jokes about like my
boobs making my money all the time
because I oh he's just crazy I mean he's
just like like do your boobs have to
make all your money why don't you put
your boobs away
I'm like dad dad
[Applause]